targeting the main artery of Russia's
economy that's how President Joe Biden
described the U.S decision to ban
Imports of Russian oil crude prices
surged again after the announcement
which comes at a time when Americans
were ready battling Rising fuel prices
the U.S Imports only a small percentage
of its oil from Russia but the ban will
likely push petrol prices even higher
Biden called it the cost of Defending
freedom
meanwhile in Europe the EU has set our
plans to end its dependence on Russian
energy by 2030 it wants to end most of
its Imports of natural gas from Russia
by the end of this year but doing it
will not be easy
Russia is now openly threatening to cut
off gas supplies to Europe completely
this would lead to enormous bottlenecks
for the entire EU
gas is primarily used to heat homes in
ovens and production processes in power
plants to produce electricity a sudden
Supply stop would push up Energy prices
dramatically
prices for oil and gas have already
risen steeply consumers are feeling the
pressure at the petrol pumps and on
their gas bills
before the Russian attack a megawatt
hour of gas cost 69 Euros already more
expensive than consumers were used to
since then in just two weeks the price
of the eex energy exchange has rocked to
a record high of 335 euros and the
Outlook is uncertain no one knows
whether Russia will make good on its
threat and turn off the tap completely
the EU now wants to completely become
independent of Russia re-power EU is the
name of its new strategy at its core
diversifying energy suppliers and
drawing more from renewable sources like
solar and biogas Renewables give us the
freedom to choose an energy source that
is clean cheap reliable and Ours
and instead of continuing to fund fossil
fuel Imports and fund Russian oligarchs
Renewables create new jobs here in
Europe the EU wants to replace
two-thirds of Russian gas Imports by the
end of the year an ambitious Target this
will end our over dependency and give us
much needed room to maneuver two-thirds
by the end of this year
it's hard
bloody heart
but it's possible if we're willing to go
further and faster than we've done
before
the EU already has plans for its energy
transition but the war in Ukraine has
officials startled forcing them to make
the switch far faster than previously
thought possible
well let's discuss Europe's energy plans
further with Mike Waterson he's an
expert in energy and Industrial
economics at the University of Warwick
in the UK thanks a lot for being with us
we just heard it described as bloody
hard by the EU the task that's ahead of
it how how ambitious are these plans
well they are they are very ambitious
and
um it's it is quite difficult to see how
things will change so quickly
um if if I might I would make maybe a
diversion uh to talk about what happened
in Germany when there was the decision
following the Fukushima earthquake to
close down
um six nuclear plants really quite
quickly yeah they'll be done by the end
of this yeah
yeah that will be uh that would that was
managed
um quite well
um partly through the fact that the
system was integrated but of course
partly through Germany burning more coal
and uh and More lignite in particular uh
in order to uh in order to satisfy
demand so I think in the short term that
again is likely to be a strategy
in the longer term what I didn't see in
the plans is much mention of storage now
producing energy from Renewables is a
well-known
technique and Germany and the UK and
various others Denmark
um have been increasing this a great
deal particularly wind and in the south
of Europe solar but none of these
produce in the same way that gas does
they don't produce uh very flexibly and
they don't necessarily produce when you
want it and that's key for electricity
so that is what our question isn't it so
it's so if if yeah they can't be getting
this now Russia where is it coming from
yeah so
um I think one of the things that's
missing is is plans for Storage storage
of energy not not necessarily storage of
gas but storage of energy once produced
electrical energy once produced and that
is
um that can be managed there are various
Technologies uh compressed air
um uh storage in dams and so on but it's
um none of that is very quick
um
right
needed right yeah because they're saying
they want to cut yeah two-thirds of
gases
yes I think in the
um in the that very short period it will
have to be more gas imports from
hopefully
um the Far East the Middle East I mean
and uh also presumably burning more coal
I'm afraid
um those are those are short-term
Solutions which go against particularly
the coal climate policy but um yeah
because
EU is talking about is essentially an
acceleration of the the the the
decarbonization of the EU isn't it it's
it's moving
getting people to to use this energy I
actually just wanted to Pivot to
something else that's been coming up
over the invasion of uh Ukraine by
Russia in it so all of the companies
we're all of a sudden saying uh stopping
operations in the country we've heard
from Starbucks now McDonald's
Coca-Cola I wanted to ask you as an
industrial expert why where suddenly
getting all of them making this decision
at the same time
right yes well I think there are a
number of potential factors I mean one
is
um public opinion these companies
um when we could instance cases these
companies have experienced uh partial
consumer boycotts in various countries
at various times McDonald's for example
has
um it could be so it could be public
opinion it could be political pressure
and I imagine that President Biden is
putting pressure on on American
companies uh such as Coca-Cola it could
be supply chain issues that they're
worried I mean again taking the example
of Coca-Cola
um presumably the role of the syrup
comes from the United States
or a limited number of Alternatives and
yes so we've got we've got a whole very
Confluence of issues coming at once I'm
sorry Mike Watson but we're actually out
of time but thank you so much for taking
the time to speak to us okay business
that's fine okay